thank you
so
i'll describe the construction of uh
graph induced
multi-linear maps from lattices this is
a
joint to walk with uh craig gentry and
uh sergei
uh so just to set the stage multi-linear
maps is a tool
it's a very powerful tool it's useful
for many things
on a very high level the thing that it
lets you do is it lets you
take quantities that you care about and
encode them in some way
that on one hand hides them on the other
hand
still lets you operate on them so at
least in that respect it's very similar
to homomorphic encryption uh the main
difference is the homomorphic encryption
is a very
all or nothing story you either have the
secret key or you don't
if you don't have the secret key then
sure you can compute as much as you want
but when you're done computing the thing
that you have in your hand is a cipher
text and it's completely meaningless to
you
alternatively maybe you do have the key
then you can decrypt the result
but then you could have decrypted also
the intermediate values or the inputs
and the special ingredients that
multilinear maps have
is that it lets you leak some
information about the result of a
computation in particular it lets you
test whether that result is equal to
zero
without letting you decrypt it if it's
not zero and without letting you um
learn anything about the intermediate
values of a computation
um and such a partial leakage is very
very powerful so you can do many things
with it
from multi-part non-interactive key
exchange through all kind of strange and
wonderful uh
encryption schemes with all kind of
strange wonderful properties
uh to code obfuscation and
many others but of course implementing
this very limited leakage that only lets
you do
that little thing and nothing else is
hard
the previous construction of
multi-linear maps they're
all based on some homomorphic encryption
schemes
uh on a very high level what they do is
they give you
a defective version of the secret key
that's good enough for testing
uh if something is a zero but not good
enough for uh decryption
uh there's one based on andrew uh due to
garg
gentry and myself and one based on
integromorphic encryption
uh due to coron le point and tibochi
and there in some sense the
algebraic algebraic and indeed the
that gives you structure that you can
exploit when you attack them
uh the feeling of these attacks
tankard will talk about it later is you
have many things that pass the zero test
many encodings of
zero and you use them to set up a system
of equations and then you solve that
system of equations
and in all of these attacks one
ingredient is computing gcds either over
integers of or other ideas in some
number field
ah but my point is there's a lot of
algebra going on there
uh so and then just again
thank you talk about it uh the clt 13
version was fixed to protect against
this attack
so before i talk about our own work let
me just
give some very high level uh lay of the
land of
what kind of attacks we have and what
kind of schemes we have and when does a
particular attack apply
so i'm not going to be very specific
here but essentially when you talk about
multilinear map there are two modes that
you can use it either
public encoding or private encoding uh
when you have private encoding
mode of usage then you require a
trapdoor information
in order to encode elements so only
the entity that generates an instance
can generate encoding in that instance
and everybody else can only compute on
those
uh encodings uh this was modeled as
multilinear jigsaw puzzles
um it's sufficient for many of the
obfuscation scheme maybe most of them
uh and for the most part none of the
attacks that we have
touch this mode of attention if this is
all you need
we have very very few attacks and
they're very weak
on the other hand the public encoding
you want to be able
for everybody to be able to encode or at
the very least to re-randomize existing
encoding this would be randomized
encoding and you want to take an
encoding of a value and generate a fresh
random encoding of the same value
when to do that you need to publish some
more stuff for everybody to use
in particular encoding of zero and this
is needed for
key agreement typically many of the
hardness assumptions actually either
needed
either to state the assumption or to use
it
and in this setting the original
encoding schemes of ggh and clt are
basically
completely broken uh and clt15 fixes it
so maybe
in clt15 can still be used in in this
one
so you need to add to publish more stuff
and if you do then these attacks apply
that's basically what i'm saying it's
okay can't you use this to attack with
private information
no because you don't in a private
economy just don't i mean if your
application is such that you don't need
to publish those things
damien
can you do a key agreement
it's a good question i think so
uh yeah i think so i mean that thing
what is this this thing mostly for
refers to the published
uh you know ggh had a key agreement and
clt i think at the same time pretty much
the same one
those things are do need that but yeah
you can build
out of obfuscation
you can actually sort of take the
obfuscation scheme assume that they're
strong enough and try to build
multi-linear map
from them that's another thing you can
do
when you say broken what does it mean i
mean there are lots of assumptions you
can make on this basically you can
recover the
encoded values if you have if you have
an encoding value you can recover the
plain text
this is as broken as you can okay but
not necessarily
learn the private parameters not
necessarily learned
in clt 13 every attack
pretty much recovers uh the secret
parameters in ggh
not always but you do get the ability to
you know i mean the key exchange is
broken and
any i can't say that the scheme is
completely
broken to the ground but i don't know of
any application where it's not broken
for that
application yeah
so what i'm talking about going to talk
about in this
uh talk is the less algebraic it only
use standard lattices and trap those
there's no i there are no ideal lattices
at least in the basic
scheme or how to factor integers there
seem to be less
structure to exploit there are no gcds
or not no obvious gcds that you can
compute
uh and it's based very loosely on a
different thermomorphic encryption
scheme the one uh due to uh gentry sahin
what does
uh in the basic settings you'd still
only get private encoding i mean the
basic setting
is still broken if you try to add direct
things to make it public encoding
uh but you can still do key agreement
that we don't know how to break
i think uh it's graph induced i'm going
to say what that is in the next slide
but it makes it a little harder to use
than the other
uh schemes at least in the basic
settings
i will talk about variants that make it
more functional
and perhaps even safe for public
encoding i'll get to that in the last
couple of slides
in the talk um
some of this talk is going to be
technical so before i get technical i
want to
have my sales pitch if you do use these
variants you get a construction that's
as useful and as secure as anything else
that we currently have
so use it to all for all of your
multilinear math needs
including if your needs are
cryptanalysis i think this scheme
deserves more cryptanalysis attention
than it has received so far
no i will not um it's a
it's so what are you going to compare it
against if you can compare it against
clt15
it's not going to be very different you
may have uh you know
square root of the security parameter
difference
yeah uh it's the complexity is similar
i i mean whether one of them is security
parameter to the fifth and the other to
the 5.5
i don't really remember but it's not
very different from the others
what is graph induced multilinear map so
the thing is
every instance of this construction is
comes with a graph and the graph tells
you which operations on encoded value
are valid you can actually compute
um it's similar to the levels that you
have in the other
constructions if you know what these are
uh you have a graph
and encodings plain text element would
be encoded relative to edges in this
graph
so here's a simple example you have a
graph with four
uh vertices and four edges and you have
an encode in
a plain text value lowercase u
encoded relative to the edge from one to
two
and what you get is the encoded value
which here is denoted as capital u
and similar other plaintext values that
are encoded relative to
other edges the once you have these
encodings the operations that you can do
on them is you can add or subtract
encoding
relative to the same edge so v and w are
encoded relative to the edge from one to
four
so you can add them or subtract them
i should say it's not edges really it's
paths
i mean these graphs by implication is
always a transitive closure of
so the dag that you get is really a
transitive closure of a graph
you can also multiply matrices that are
on adjacent
uh edges in a path so u and x
are on one one edge after another in a
path so you can multiply these two
matrices
and what you get is an encoding of the
product u
times x relative to the path from one to
four
and once you have that then you can add
and subtract it from
v and w
and you can uh zero test if you have an
encoding
for that but for that version let's say
that any encoding anywhere in the graph
uh you can test whether that thing
encodes a zero or not
uh so this is the functionality uh that
uh graph based multi-linear maps give
you and there is there are some
yep yeah so just to make sure that the
graphs are acidic
yes
you can make it cyclic but then at least
the basic form would be broken
and i don't know about the variance that
i'll present at the end i didn't think
about it
um
yes yes it's a transitive closure always
yes and actually it's more than that i
mean you can
sort of with that loss of generality or
almost without loss of generality assume
that there is a single source in a
single thing
i never tried to really characterize
what kind of graphs are useful there but
just like a path uh i mean it's not uh
it's a cyclic and threat let me at the
very last slide i talk a little bit
about what graphs are useful so let me
get there
zero test for now zero test is any
encoding anywhere in the graph but you
can have variants where only the
source to sync things can be zero tested
um and you need some security so the
very basic uh
property that you want which is
necessary but not sufficient for
anything uh is that you cannot recover
the plaintext encodings from
and the plaintext values from the
encodings
so just one more question so when you
can multiply
can you multiply really is it two parts
that
yes yes if you have two two encodings on
two paths on the graph
then you can mult if the if they're
consecutive you can multiply them and
you get an encoding relative to the
concatenated path
i don't think it corresponds to a graph
structure like i
i was trying to think about it i don't
think it corresponds to a graph
structure
security is more like a one-way function
than semantics well you would need much
more than that but you would say that a
scheme is broken if that doesn't hold
right i mean i i'm not going to talk
about
security assumptions at all i'm just
going to present this
scheme as it is and then you can make
whatever assumption you have
i'll describe to you the essentially
only attacks that we know how to mount
and you can
this attack breaks that uh
so currently partly because not too many
people have looked at it
we're in the setting that either you can
completely break it or we don't know
anything at all that you can do
uh so here is a simple application that
you can try to implement from that
uh non-interactive but multi-part key
agreement so in this case
three parties alice bob and charlie they
want to agree on a key
uh in our setting there are some public
parameters that everybody know
including the attacker eve uh and
you want a scheme where each one of them
just independently broadcasts something
and once everybody heard everybody
else's broadcast then they can agree on
a secret key
whereas eve even though she knows the
public parameter and heard all the
broadcast announcement
doesn't know what the key is so here is
one way to do it based on uh
graph based multi-linear maps we're
gonna have three chains one from alice
one for bob and one for
uh charlie and alice would encode the
same value
on one edge in each chain
would pop would broadcast the values on
bob's and charlie's uh chains but will
keep the value on her own chain to
herself
and similarly bob will do the same and
so charlie
and then the shelled key is just a times
b times c each one of them has a chain
where it knows all of the encoded values
so they can compute an encoding of a
times b
times c uh but eve is missing one edge
on every chain
so she can't
right so there's a question that now
they have different encodings of the
same value how do they recover the value
let's say that they can
i didn't i mean the interface that i
described doesn't actually let you do
that
it does let you do it if uh you know
each one of them either encode the right
value or not and then
either they're good they get a zero or
one but that's a little complicated and
these schemes
at least in the basic form always let
you uh
extract some random value out of an
encoding
so i didn't talk about it
so far there is no assumption so far
there was only functionality
right and this and this thing if you
want this to be
secure key exchange assuming that you
get the functionality as per anna's
question
then you would make an assumption saying
it's a security exchange
and it would translate to some
assumption not particularly natural one
but some assumption on the underlying
encoding
and so you had a picture of the graph
and you explain how these edges
and vertices mean are you so are you
going to show us
that for every scheme you need a
different graph
actually
at this point every scheme so here for
example every key exchange scheme would
need
that depend where the length of the the
change is as many as the number of
parties
um this scheme like if you want to do a
fuscation which i'm not by the way i'm
not going to talk about it
other than showing the picture you need
a single chain
uh whose length is as long as your
branching program
uh so at this point the way i said it so
far
every scheme would need a different
graph and when you design your scheme
figure out what graph you need
at the end i will say that actually i
don't know if any interesting thing that
doesn't
that cannot just get by with a single
chain uh
so maybe this whole graph thing is just
red herring and you always can use
chains i don't know the way we thought
about it initially
started from really graphs but uh the
way i
think about it right now i don't know if
the graphs mean anything
needs a chain and you if you have a
security assumption
uh if you run a generic security
assumption on this multi-linear map it
would say for every graph
uh something for every graph you cannot
distinguish between this distribution of
things encoded on the edges
and that distribution of things encoded
at the edges that would
probably be uh uh
you know if you want to replicate the
file pass
assumption then it would say for every
uh sequence of graph and every two
distribution of things that are encoded
on the edges
if in some generic model you cannot
distinguish these two distribution then
also on the encoding you cannot
distinguish this would be the the
structure of the
of the assumption that you would be
making
yeah so i'm not going to say anything
about this about this slide
so uh let me go quickly through the
tools we've
seen these tools uh over and over again
in this workshop so i'm not gonna
say much about them other than let you
appreciate my color schemes
um learning with ls
some parameters there's m and n there
are the dimensions of these matrices
these are
wide and short matrices uh
q which is a modulus uh the decision
version of learning with error at least
in this formulation would be
uh you get a random matrix uh n
by m matrix mod q and
another matrix b and your job is to
determine whether b is a random matrix
or whether b was obtained as
some secret matrix s times a plus e
so in words whether or not b are the
columns the rows of b are close to the
row space of a
ah s is typically random and small but
it was shown
is random and small and and s is
typically random and small but it was
shown by
upper bound and r that uh you can assume
that s is as small as e
um so that's uh the
the formulation of lwe that we will use
in this uh
uh work and trapdoors we talked a little
bit less about them during this workshop
but the point is you can sample a pair
a and tower tau is a
a is almost uniform mod q and tau is
some trapdoor
information about a one particular form
of disruptor information that would be
relevant
to some of the attacks that i will show
later uh
is if you have a full rank matrix t
m by m this is the big dimension m
uh it's full rank over the integers but
when you look at it mode q
then a times t 0 mod q
and if you have a trapdoor like that
either in this form or any other
forms that were proposed in the
literature then
you can solve hard problems relative to
that particular a so you can solve lw
relative to that a given b which is s
times a plus e
you can find s uh and if in fact you
don't
this need this to be an lw instance you
don't need
e and s to be distributed according to
whatever distribution lw
is whenever you have something that
looks like that for a small e you can
find s
and you can also find uh solve the small
integer
solution problem relative to that a that
is if you have that a
and you have a target matrix r you can
find
a matrix that uh when you multiply it by
a gives you
r uh and moreover well that you can
always find that's just
solving as a linear set of equation but
you can find a small one
you can find the small d m by m d
such that a times d equals r mod q
uh so with that uh let me describe the
construction the one thing new in this
construction is this particular way of
representing
lwe instances so you have an lw instance
uh
a b that's the two matrices that you get
in an lw instance
and then you have some auxiliary matrix
a prime
and we want to represent b relative to a
prime
by a small matrix d such that a prime
times
d equals b so we're going to solve a
small integer
solution relative to a prime
uh which you can do if we have a
trapdoor for a prime but we don't need a
trapdoor for a
so the lwe instance could still be hard
uh so this is a particular way uh that
turns out to be useful of representing
uh
lw instances and in our construction
we're gonna have these matrices a for
all the graphs
so you can think of this one as the
matrix corresponding to the
uh destination and this one as the
matrix corresponding to the source and
then we're going to have
uh we might have a trap relative to one
of them but not the other
yep
well if if we were lucky and be able to
prove i need to reduce anything to lw it
would be that kind of thing that we'll
be using we don't know how to reduce
anything there to lwe so it's not
it's not that i can make that assumption
and then prove anything in this
statement this is an
intuition why the scheme is not broken
right but yeah again i i'm not going to
have any formal assumptions simply
because
essentially we don't know how to make
them uh so i'm going to describe what
i'm describing to you as a candidate
um it would be nice to
come up with clean assumptions that
would imply hardness i
we just don't know how to do it yet
if you could break lw you can definitely
break the scheme if this is what you're
asking
speaking of a prime is publicly yeah in
our case a prime would be public and
actually a will not be but
yeah so it
looks further a little farther than the
lwe than
you'd think by this description but yeah
um
that's this that's all i'm saying here
um
so okay now we can describe the
construction
uh we are given this dag and of course
also the lwe parameter
and mq and for every node we're going to
choose a random matrix one of these
wide and short matrices a together with
a trapdoor
and the things that we're going to
encode our plain text
are lwe secrets so the thing we're
encoding our small matrices mode q
small n by n this is the smaller
dimension matrices mod q
and once we have uh these matrices
a with their trap doors and we want to
encode
a value s relative to a particular edge
from u to v
then we first just generate an lwe
instance relative
to the matrix at the end of that path
and then encodes b relative to the
matrix at the beginning of that path
so we have we need to trap those only
for the matrix at the beginning in order
to generate
uh this encoding but think about it if
you want to
generate encoding relative to many
matrices then you need
to trap though relative to many of these
so in particular
in order to represent to generate an
accounting relative to this edge
you need an encode trap the relative to
this matrix
so you can that's why we cannot reduce
it to lw because then you cannot say
anything about the security of
matrices here but for every
individual encoding at least you can say
that uh
that you can generate it without being
able to break the lw instance
uh in other words if d
is an encoding of s relative to the edge
from udv
then you have the relation that a sub u
times d is roughly s times a sub v
plus a little bit of error that's that's
the property of encoding that we have
uh and if we have that uh
so in order to come up with this
encoding you need to control
the destination i need to have
a trapdoor for the source
so does that mean in the key exchange
protocol that you showed everybody needs
to know the trapdoor for the
intermediate nodes
no so
in to do the key exchange you would
actually go halfway
to the uh to the public encoding and
generate many
you know what let me get to the like two
slides from here and then answer it
do i need well
let's say that yes okay i mean s is the
secret that you're encoding so you
needed to have
a high entropy in the same sense that
you need
uh the exponent in in diffie-hellman to
have high entropy
if you're publishing s
well it's it's an n by n matrix it's
small you
it has high entropy but yeah
so so far with what you've told us
it is true that it's hard to invert the
encoding right
yes okay so i didn't i didn't say what
you publish yet but uh yeah
yes uh
okay let's let's go over the operations
addition well
if a1 times c is s times a4
and a1 times c prime is s prime times a4
so
you have these two encodings then you
add the matrices and
and what you get is an encoding of the
sum of the
s's um multiplication
also works if you have uh a1 times ds
s times a2 and a2 times d prime is
s prime times a4 then you multiply the
ds
and you open the parenthesis and what
you get is close to
s times s4 times a4
in the previous case the l was just
added in this case the arrow has a more
complicated form
uh it's one arrow times the encoding
plus the other arrow times the plaintext
so if you want the l to remain small you
need both the encoding and the plaintext
to be small which is why we have it this
way in the construction
one thing that i want to say here is
that if you remember
from uh the first day where we were
using this magic
g uh um gadget
that lets you uh you take a matrix
that's not really small
and then you stretch it according to
along one dimension and you represent it
as a smaller
you could ask whether you could use it
here uh and the answer is
not that we know of i mean there is one
way of using it where the dimensions
match but that one way is broken um
so and the reason is because we're going
to make these a's public i mean in
things like gsw this a's represent
really the
the secret key uh and it's kept secret
uh
but if you publish it then it's a
problem
right uh zero test
how do you do it yep so you have
encodings
with respect to specific vertices right
right so when you when you multiply
relative to edges
right right so when you multiply you get
according relative to paths
in general you always have encoding
relative to paths as i said you
really should think of this graph as a
transitive closure of a graph
so then when you multiply is that is the
encoding of the result
with respect like what to the path from
the beginning to the end
okay so like in your previous example
the
the multiplication is with respect to to
the path from one to four so you can
it was going to be respect to that path
so if you had other encodings on this
edge you could have added them
afterwards
which are not really like i don't know
like i have two passwords
so something like this not really i mean
the the thing that you can do
is if you have paths that end at the
same point and you can recognize
whenever they encode the same value
but you can't do any any operations on
them which is why i said that really
morally it's always a single source in a
single path
a single thing
all right zero tests how do you zero
test well if i give you the a's then you
just multiply
by these a's and check that it's small
and it would be small if it's an
encoding of a zero because
we said that an encoding of an of s
relative to the edge from u to v
satisfy a times u is s times s times av
plus e so if
s was a zero then you're left with only
the error of the matrix which is small
so if i give you these a's um
then you can recognize zeros and if it's
not a zero
then a times u is roughly s times a sub
v
a sub v is random if s is not a zero
then
s times a v is large so therefore so is
a u times d
so it lets you distinguish encodings of
zero from encoding of nonzero
so that's the functionality and
zero test you need to get both matrices
no just the
source matrix
yes i will i will say that i have like
two or three slides at the end about
variance in this variant
uh i can only give you the encode the
matrix for the source and then you would
only be able to zero test
uh encoding relative to paths that begin
at the source uh but if i want to only
let you in uh
zero test things relative to source to
sync
then i need to do something else and i
will mention it at the end
if there's something i don't understand
so if
a sub b is public then can't you just
test for if you have if you know s
whether
you can yes if a sub v was public and
i'm not going to give it
i'm only going to give things relative
to the source matrices
yeah it's true i mean at the beginning i
said that i'll let you test for zero
anywhere else and that's
if you knew s you could have tested with
that but that's true also
if you have the discrete log in mind if
you think you know what the discrete log
then you can test it
so it's not very different from here
if i if i if i give a sub v then i let
you test for every s whether it's equal
to s
which is somewhat more extended version
of the zero test
um right if you don't give
a sub i only give a sub u then you can
only test things at paths that begin at
a sub u
at the node u and that's
i mean yeah that's the question again so
this is what you need to publish for
zero tests just the au matrices and now
do we have the properties that the
encodings are hard to invert you've been
given a zero
based on that even if you give all of
the a's
then you still not based on lw no uh if
right if you only have a single edge i
can prove it based on lwa
anything more com interesting than that
i cannot
uh i don't i don't i don't know how to
break it but i can't reduce it that way
just because the fact that
if you need in order to generate these
encodings
well i can do it at some something one
thing that's a little more interesting
than a path is
everywhere except one place there's at
most a single matrix and
in one edge there are many matrices that
i can still reduce to lwe
but that's it you're saying
this specific graph i'm saying if i have
a particular
labeled graph graph of things where it's
a one chain
everywhere i have just a single matrix
on all of the edges except one on one of
the edges i can have more than one
and on this thing i can say that if
you i'm not even sure about
publishing the original i think i can
still show that it's how to recover the
original thing based on lw
not sure but it's not again it's not an
interesting graph in the sense that
you can't really do anything with it
um all right who can encode this is uh i
think uh you've gonna ask a question
related to that
you need to know trapdoors doing code
you need to know the trapdoor of the
source matrix
if you want to encode over a path you
need to know the trapdoors of all the
matrices but one
uh so it's private encoding uh you can
go beyond private encoding by uh
generating many uh inc random encoding
of random s's
and just publish those and then you can
take a
subset some of them or maybe a gaussian
linear combination of them and using the
gaussian
left over hash lemma to claim that the
result is an encoding of uh
of a random s um
and there there's a question of whether
or not it's safe to pub to make the sis
public
in some version of it we know that it's
not in other versions we don't know but
let's assume that you don't need that
uh that you don't publish it uh the key
exchange
protocol that i described before was
written the way it was written
so that you can do it so that you can
run it without
publishing the encodings of this
and so that we don't know how to break
it so
it's it's essentially a private key uh
encoding scheme you can go
slightly beyond private key encoding but
not very much i mean if you try to go
too far we have attacks
and i'm going to show you the main
attacks that we have
now uh just to show you what uh what the
what the issue is when when you try to
walk with this
um or you cannot have a community
community version
event so far the plaintext is a matrix
if you
remember the the key exchange example
they were computing them in different
orders so they actually don't get an
encoding of the same thing
if you want them to get an encoding of
the same thing then you need the plain
text
operations to commute so you can work
with one by one matrices and that would
work except you need to walk over a
larger ring because
otherwise the lw instance would be easy
to solve
uh so you walk over larger rings i mean
you take one of these cycloatomic rings
and you walk over that
and then you get n equals one m is going
to be log q
um and even in this case i want to
stress that the encodings commute
ah the so the encoded values commute the
encodings do not the encodings are still
log n by logan matrices so they don't
commute so you can still only multiply
them in the order
in the prescribed order but the thing
the value that's encoded there
you can compute it in many different
ways yeah so
this is saying to actually do uh
to make these a matrices now single row
yes
yes but could you not also work with
just
a sub ring of n by n matrices that
correspond to
this r here but leave the a matrices as
uh you can but do you does that give you
anything
well so it would allow that i mean it
makes the plaintext space equal to r
while still making the l w matrices
you know 10 by m yeah you can do that
over the q yeah but then you'll see
lwe secret is then just a single
no it's a it's still a matrix but it's
it's a from a sub ring of
matrices that questions commute yeah
they commute because the corresponds to
the ring are
it's plausible i didn't think about it
but yeah
i think it well i think it does work
all right so let me describe the attacks
uh
there's essentially one and it's that
if i give you an encoding of 0 what is
an encoding of 0 and encoding of 0
relative to the edge from v to w
is a matrix d such that a sub v times d
is small which means that it's almost a
0. now if it was exactly a 0 d
would have been a trapdoor for a sub v
uh
and the attack is just observing that
you can use d as if it was
essentially as as if it was a trap door
uh essentially anything that you can do
with a trap door for
a sub v you can do with this matrix
which is almost a trapdoor
and the way to do to see that is well
now we have a sub
v times d equals e where e is small but
we want it to be equal to zero
so let's make let's make it zero if i
know a sub v
and i know d then i know the matrix e so
i can just look at the matrix minus d
on top of e and that time when i
multiply it by
a sub v prime which is a sub v with the
identity then i do get zero
so this is closer to being a trap though
not quite a trapdoor yet because it's
not full rank
now a sub v prime has m plus
n columns and this matrix is only a
franc m
uh so i need a little bit more so let me
let me get a little bit more suppose i
have two encodings of zero
relative to that edge so now i have two
of these matrix minus d over e and i
just concatenate them and now i have
enough columns and with high probability
uh i get enough linearly independent uh
columns and then i get a full trapdoor
for the matrix
a sub v prime so i started
by encodings of zero i get a real
working trapdoor for a related matrix
it's not exactly the matrix a sub
but it's close enough and it's close
enough in order to break
now i have a trapdoor for this i can
break lwe
on this relative to encoding on this
edge so now i have it
an arbitrary encoding on that edge
and right so i have an encoding
of c relative to the edge from u to v
so a sub u times c is
s times a v plus error and i'm going to
call a sub u
times c the matrix b if i know a
sub u i can compute the matrix b uh
i want to have an lwe instance relative
to
a u a v prime not a v so i'll make it an
lw instance relative to that matrix just
by concatenating zeros
uh now i have b prime times s
equals s times a v prime plus e prime
uh plain text is small so that thing is
still small error
it doesn't really comply with the lwe
distribution but we don't care i mean we
can use drop doors to
to solve even if it's just a bdd
instance
so the moral of this thing if i have
zeros with respect to v time v going to
u
so i can have zeros relative to a path
in the graph only in that
if that path begins at a source because
this is the only case
where i will never see instances where
that chapter helps me solve it
so that's that's the moral of the story
and you can actually extend it
so you don't need to have uh uh
encoding of zero you can on a path you
can have an encode two encodings
of the same value on two paths that lead
to
jo a mutual endpoint and you can repeat
then the the previous tricks
um and then if you have encoding of the
same thing on all of these edges then
you can find it
that's that thing uh and you can even
extend it some further you can
have encoding of different s's
on many paths with this joint endpoint
as long as you know a small linear
combination that annihilates them
uh and they've all i mean i'm not going
to go through that because i'm a little
out of time but all of these things
work just the same
so these types of attack since it's
essentially the only attacks that we
know how to mount
they suggest a generic model and the
intuition is if you can get trapdoor
then the scheme is broken if you cannot
get trapdoor then the scheme is
as secure as you could possibly hope uh
it is a generic model
it's credible in the sense that well for
all we know
these are this is the cryptanalysis
landscape here
um and you can actually formulate what
does it mean to get a trapdoor it's
encoding on paths with common endpoints
that we know how to annihilate and none
of these paths begin at the source
it should be possible to formalize uh
it should be not particularly hard to
prove uh
security of value schemes in particular
obfuscation schemes
and we really don't have any meaningful
attacks beyond this generic model
as of yet so it would be also
interesting to find ones
to get a better understanding uh
so so if you have a zero test but you're
not allowed to have encodings of zeros
you can have encoding of zero and paths
that begin at the source
but not any other paths
it's okay it's just like this low level
versus not low
level level encodings of zero in the
other encode
multi-linear maps here too if you have
encodings of zero relative to paths from
source to
sink or from source to anything else
then the only trapdoor that you can get
is trapped
relative to this uh a sub and we don't
we you will never see an lwe instance
relative to that
uh sits close to the source and you
allow it it's a path that begins at a
source
any path any path that you multiply
would still begin at a source
you can never you can never push the
beginning of the of the path anywhere
else
again no the the path that you get is
the source to think
right i mean you multiply one uh matrix
on every edge you get a matrix relative
to the
entire path
so no if you don't
i mean if these s's that you publish
are kept secret then you don't know how
to annihilate them and if they're random
then
you don't get encodings of zero you're
getting coding of random asses that you
don't know what they are
so yeah that's i admit that it looks
like uh somewhat of a lame defense but
no i don't know how to use it
so you don't need to publish
something not in the key exchange
application
i need to publish encoding of random
stuff but not zeros
right all right let me talk about some
variants
uh these are things that are sort of
mentioned in passing in the
uh in the paper uh the particular
presentation
is due to some discussion that i had
with ron over the last couple of days
um
the first thing that you might want to
do is
say that uh publishing uh these
small entry matrices d is a little scary
cryptanalysis wise
so you may want to strengthen it and
here is one very natural way of
strengthening it
uh you just in addition to everything
that you've chosen so far you also
choose a random invertible matrix
t relative to the uh edge to the nodes
except things where you just use the
identity
and then uh
essentially you multiply you replace an
encoding c
by an encoding t u times c times t v
inverse this is kilian
like randomization the point is this
thing is no longer small and the t's are
never revealed
uh and you need to replace your source
by a different
matrix but that's just uh so that things
cancel out at the end
uh it doesn't affect any source to sync
encoding
and now you can already pop if i publish
this
guy i would let you test for zero over a
source to sync
edge path but not over any other path
because any other path that would end
before the sync
uh would still have this extra thing
packed at the end
yeah so the encoding now is large i mean
it's like as big as q so yeah
no because i mean the the thing
underlying it remains the same and these
things cancel out as you uh
as you multiply
so you cannot now if i need to produce i
need to know the trapdoor for the source
now i need to know the travelers for the
source
and the two mattresses one for the
sources of the scene
you still need trapdoors and all of the
t's and everything else in order to
generate
only the generator of this uh
on the of this scheme
previously i needed only for the source
you don't need to trap or anything to
use the encodings you don't need to know
any trapdoors or anything at all
your generating coding you need all the
trapdoors for everything
well yeah now you now you need uh now
you need more but
the the assumption is you generate the
scheme you generate the encoding to
begin with
uh you publish it and then uh so here is
one thing that you can do in this case
this seems to kill the trapdoor attacks
i don't know how to extend the trap
those attack
attacks to this setting uh if it really
kills it then maybe now it's safe to
publish encodings of zero so now you can
re-randomize things
maybe you can even publish an encoding
together with the encoded value
and then you can generate yourself by
taking subset sums
uh encoding a random element and it's
encoding
so it seems to let you a lot more a lot
more room to play and
again it's not that anybody has tried
particularly hard to break this
this variant but i tried for a little
bit and failed
uh and it is mentioned in the in the
paper but it was not stressed very much
uh here's another one uh
levels i mean levels are wonderful you
can do struggling sets with them and
stuff
can't we have levels here yeah sure we
can uh just you know
divide this encoding by the denominator
z
and multiply the the product of the zi's
into the zero test and everything works
and everything is fine
you do need large rings uh if these
these were uh
all safeguards and probably both um
no safeguards by itself is not enough
you do need large rings for that because
otherwise you at the end of the day you
have a matrix
and you know that there is a single
scalar such that if you multiply it into
this matrix you get something small
so if this was a scalar over zq then
it's a lot of dimension one and you can
find it
also you do need the ring to be large uh
if you're going to use
these levels but you can you can use
this level you get
all the levels that you like from ggh
and clt back
um and moreover this is even a little
more a little nicer to use than uh
than ggh and clt in the sense that it
enforces the order of products because
you still have the chain
and you encode the entire matrix
together as opposed to individual
elements in fact
in in this in my discussion with one it
seems that you can just use it to encode
barrington as
is without any random and randomization
on this side of the construction itself
and seems that it's still secure
i mean you do get the kilian
randomization of course
when you implement the multi-linear maps
with this variant but
um right
so let me conclude only ten minutes
behind schedule
uh less algebraic instruction we have
this variant with
uh safeguards and levels that seems to
be as good
if not better than any other alternative
that we currently have for
any construct almost any construction
that you can think of
um
would be nice to understand this this uh
warrant a little better for example what
happens when you try to use it to encode
a very low rank secret a secret
that is really just uh um
you know have rank one um so
it's not a zero so you can't apply zero
test but maybe there you can still uh
just do or if not if if low rank secrets
are just as safe as any other secret
then you can do sub group elimination
but you by using eigenspaces
instead of these different uh groups um
here's one thing that i'm just curious
about i can't think if you have these
levels i can't think of any application
that actually needs a graph
they all can get by with a chain is
there any application that where the
graph actually buys you anything i don't
know
uh and you know the big one i mean
it's always plausible that you can say
under lwe and
something or the other this thing is
secure
you definitely need lwe to be hard for
this not to be broken it's not
sufficient but
maybe there is some relatively simple to
state assumption that would give you
i don't know multilinear ddh or
something
i don't know so yeah that's it
so can you briefly maybe uh explain this
exchange i mean initially you explain it
in one way but then it seems like your
formula
wasn't consistent so if i want to do key
exchange
there is some graph which generates a
graph and he gives each person something
so you encode the same
uh let me go back all the way there
is the only question is how do you do
the encoding i mean
the construction is the same
right but the question is how do you do
this encoding how does alice do this in
coding
so the generator will generate many
random
encodings on this edge and encoding us
the same random thing on this edge and
encoding of the same random thing on
this edge
and then all this will just take the
same subset sum here here and there
um so essentially each guy gets a bunch
of
uh you know everything labeled there i
get a bunch of uh
encodings of i think
the same little a on this and then i
start taking linear
same linear combination giving us yes
so this is a non-test graph right or
you're saying now you can do this across
right so if i had the if i had the
levels i could do it with puffs
not entirely i'm not entirely
clear about i mean maybe maybe you don't
even need le i mean for this application
i'm not exactly sure what happens if you
just put all of them on the same
link maybe it's it also works not sure